thank you for the introduction brittany
hi everyone i'm sushi khanda producer on
resident evil village
resident evil village has been created
with the concept of a beautiful yet
terrifying village in mind and we have
poured a passion
into creating this experience for our
fans
of course it also has the combat
resource management
and horror elements you expect from
resident evil
we've also made sure there's plenty of
gameplay content as well
in the previous showcase we told you
that we'd have another demo ready for
you across multiple platforms
well i'm happy to announce that the next
demo experience will be available on
playstation 5
playstation 4 xbox series x
xbox one steam and stadia
in new of the game event that we were
unable to hold
we have prepared a special day where you
can experience resident evil village
here are the details on what need to be
[Music]
available
you'll have a total of 60 minutes to
explore
both the village and castle areas
you're free to spend one full hour for
both stages
or choose which one you want to play
it's up to you where you spend your
survival horror experience
playstation 5 and playstation 4 owners
will also get early access as well
we've titled it 8 hours in village
we have the details for you here
in honor of resident evil village being
the eighth major installment of the
franchise
you will have an 8 hour window to try
out the demo for 30 minutes
playstation players will have early
access to the village section first
followed by the castle section for the
re access players
feel free to also stream and share your
breakthrough to the world
we hope that with your help we will be
able to show off the demo to everyone
and for the multiple platform demo we
hope that
all players from all over the world will
be able to
enjoy the resident evil village demo
finally
players will be able to pre-draw the
demo ahead of time
playstation 5 and playstation 4 owners
are able to pre-download the demo
starting today
please visit our official website for
more details
we hope you enjoyed this upcoming sneak
peek
at the next generation of survivor
horror